c'est bien connu les pommes de terre ont
tendance à germer si on les oublie trop
longtemps et dans les entrepôts des
maladies les guettent également pour les
protéger on utilise depuis des années un
pesticide contreversé mais il ya une
lueur d'espoir sous la forme d'une
substance issue de la forêt boréale
[Musique]
frêche en frite ou en croustilles la
pomme de terre est populaire au canada
nous en consommons près de 58 kg chacun
par année ce qui en fait notre légumes
préférés
oui oui un légume loin devant la tomate
en europe aussi la pomme de terre à son
public
mais depuis octobre 2020 la commission
européenne interdit l'utilisation du
produit le plus répandu dans le monde
contre la germination des pommes de
terre en entrepôt le chlore pro femme ou
ses eee pc à cause des risques pour la
santé
c'est surtout concernant sa toxicité
autant dans l'environnement que du côté
des consommateurs aussi parce que le cpc
il va être très persistant c'est que au
niveau de la transformation ne monte pas
des pommes de terre on retrouve du cpc
ou de ses métabolites de dégradations
dans l'huile de friture ou encore même
dans les frites mais santé canada en
permet toujours l'utilisation
l'institution se base sur son évaluation
de 2008 et la prochaine est prévue en
2023/2024 aucune discussion n'est en
cours au mapaq
nous produisons au pays près de 5
millions de tonnes de pommes de terre
chaque année elles sont récoltées de
juillet à octobre puis entreposés pour
être distribués aux consommateurs tout
au long de l'année avec un happy
germinatif avec un contrôle de
température contrôle de l'humidité dans
les capable de fournir
m'a dit mon passé mal d'entreposage mais
chaque année cet entreposage cause la
perte de 10% de la récolte une perte
chiffrée à 75 millions de dollars
très efficace le cibc est aussi le moins
cher sur le marché
on s'y attaque pas soit être cuits par
le propre gouverneur ou encore ça
pourrait être un joueur majeur qui était
revenu ir et lui d'acheter les coyotes a
continué pendant ce temps les
producteurs de pommes de terre prennent
les devants ils ont contacté des
scientifiques pour trouver un nouvel
anti germinatif tout commence en 2018
dans les laboratoires de l'université du
québec à trois-rivières et se dit nos
fibres michel boivin est alors étudiante
chercheuse associée à ce projet notre
idée c'est d'utiliser les écorces
toujours en ayant procédé plus
écologique de fabrication qui en bout de
ligne on aura aussi un impact moindre et
sur la santé des consommateurs mais
aussi des là sur la santé des
producteurs de pommes de terre comme les
écorces d'arbre compte aussi des
propriétés antimicrobiennes les
chercheuses pensent qu'elle pourrait
régler un deuxième problème dans les
entrepôts celui du développement des
maladies dans les pommes de terre
donc nous avec nos écoles on a voulu
vraiment étudier s'il n'y avait pas un
potentiel antimicrobiens et andy
germinatif elle récupère des écorces des
branches et des aiguilles dans les
résidus de la cogénération de saint
félicien au lac saint jean avant qu'ils
soient brûlées comme source d'énergie
on a travaillé avec le bouleau jaune
l'épinette noire qui aussi les sapins
baumiers qu'on ne fait plusieurs tests
puis qu'en bout de ligne c'est vraiment
l'épinette noire qui en ressort les
grands gagnants on a fait des tests anti
germinatif on appliquer directement nos
extraits de toutes les sortes d'armes
sur la surface de nos pommes de terre
après un mois seulement on pouvait déjà
allé voir les patates qu'on avait traité
s'il y avait eu des germes ce qu'on veut
pas elle suit les mêmes étapes pour
trouver un antimicrobien efficace après
avoir inoculé des maladies après des
mois de recherche les résultats en
laboratoire sont concluants
il faut maintenant passer à l'échelle
des tests en entrepôt qui nécessite de
grandes quantités d'extrait d'épinette
noire
disponible sous forme d'huiles
essentielles pour l'action anti
germinative il faut par contre fabrique
l anti microbiens tôt la chimiste
nathalie bourdeau prend le relais
le défi dans ce projet c'est vraiment
d'arriver à isoler les molécules actives
dans notre ingrédients qui font fi des
molécules combien sortir des escortes et
il faut arriver à optimiser le procédé
pour que ce soit à l'échelle
industrielle le plus économique possible
pour que ce soit viable
on est très excités par la journée
d'aujourd'hui on est content tout se
passe bien donc on a pris les écorces
pour notre mii dans les réacteurs avec
une certaine quantité d'eau et sous
l'effet d'achats la louve aller chercher
les molécules d'intérêt dans les écorces
et on ramène à 6 lits molécules qui se
trouvent dans les liquides ça va se
retourner sous forme de poudre qui va
être formulée pour pouvoir était petit
sur les pommes de terre à l'entreposage
nathalie bourdeau et michel boivin
rejoignent sophie massy dans les
entrepôts de recherche à sainte croix de
lotbinière pour la prochaine étape des
tests à l'échelle industrielle
[Musique]
avoir un contrôle avec le fils pc pour
vous les comparez les résultats au
courant de la thèse en entreposage
les tubercules circulent sur un
convoyeur pour être traité par
pulvérisation des différents extraits
pour le volet à tout ira bien
nous avons testé trois pattes à jambes
des pattes avant qu'on retrouve
couramment dans les entrepôts de québec
pour tous créé par les bactéries
pathogènes terium musique ailleurs on
suit pourri sur seiche jean adret pas le
fusarium et peu comme on le voit les
anti-jo menacé pour nos tests et on va
tester les les huiles et les excès
quelques mois plus tard la chercheuse
analyse les effets des traitements sur
les milliers de pommes de terre
entreposés
l'évaluation hebdomadaire qu'on fait
pour relever la germination des
tubercules concept à évaluer s'il ya des
gens de moins de 2000 mètres notre
recette et 2 contres combien il ya des
germes de plus de 2000 mètres et ensuite
on compte on mesure le germe le plus
long set et les pommes de terre témoin
contrôle en fait il y aurait reçu aucun
extrait la journée entière passablement
avancé sur cette variété là
ce qu'on va voir tantôt avec la tige en
bois puis les pommes de terre traiter
aussi pc ne présente presque aucun germe
donc pour les trois faits falloir trois
sophie et son équipe arrivent maintenant
à la boîte qui contient les pommes de
terre traiter avec lui l'essentiel
d'épinette noire
être le produit a brûlé légèrement donc
aucun genre de plus de 2000 mètres et
aucun germe de moins de 2000 mac pour
lentilles germinatif
les résultats sont comparables aux 6 pc
non qu'on ne peut observer une unique
question aux alentours de 94 95 pour sa
du contrôle de la germination pour les
tests anti microbiens elle cherche le
développement de pourriture molle ou de
pourriture sèche une fonctionnaire deux
forces du mal on a des très bons
résultats
comparativement aux contrôles où la
majorité des tubercules était était
malade et si on peut voir il ya tout le
mois d'août bercu sur les 25 sont
affectées
l'extrait de lunettes noires et efficace
pour certaines maladies notamment là
pour tout le mal causé par la bac et du
pq bactérienne on parle d'une efficacité
d'environ 90 pour ça faut savoir qu'au
québec il ya très très peu de produits
homologués pour contrôler la pourriture
mal post récolte donc un entrepôt dans
une très bonne nouvelle quand un produit
prometteur pour ce genre de manège
on y est bien content des résultats
qu'on a obtenus jusqu'à maintenant tant
au niveau de l'ingrédient anti
germinatif que de l'ingrédient
antimicrobiens maintenant avant de se
rendre au niveau commercial il reste
quand même plusieurs étapes à réaliser
que ce soit d'un côté démontré
l'innocuité de ces produits là parce que
ça aurait été appliquée sur les éléments
d'un autre c'est de démontrer que ça
n'affecte pas la qualité des pommes de
terre que ce soit au niveau du goût de
la couleur parce que ça peut avoir un
impact avant les transforme par exemple
comment croustilles
alors c'est tout des choses qui vont
rester à étudier ces études vont durer
plusieurs années avant l'homologation du
produit
si tous les critères sont remplis il
pourrait être fabriqué dans une nouvelle
usine à saint félicien on est très
optimistes que nos produits québécois se
retrouve être les producteurs de pommes
de terre autant que beck ailleurs au
canada
[Musique]
m